hey Doug Walker here I just saw us and
this is my spoiler free review of it off
the bet
yeah I like this movie this is again
without getting into too much detail
because as well though you can't keep
some of the surprises in there there's
pretty much a family that I believe they
go on vacation and they're confronted by
another family but it seems to be them
it looks just like them doesn't really
act like them but there's some similar
things they do like they'll move like
them if like one moves backwards eeeh
they might move backwards but they're
not always mirroring them so it's just
about this family trying to get away
from this other family where did this
other family come from what's their plan
and are there more of them with you how
many of them are there if there are and
it's just kind of working around that
this is of course by Jordan Peele who
did get out and my first big concern
going into this was that this was gonna
be a little too much repeat cuz I saw
the trailer it didn't look bad but I was
kind of like alright this kinda looks
like another thing with kind of identity
and you know there's another you or you
you know similar ideas not like a direct
ripoff but I was kind of like oh is this
always going to be the thing and it's
for the most part not it it kind of does
stuff a little differently and a big
part of that honestly is probably the
comedy there is comedy in this but and
get out where I thought the comedy
worked best when it came from just the
situation itself not really the
one-liners and there were a lot of
one-liners that they try to put in there
hear that a lot more the comedy comes
from the situation there is an
occasional one-liner that for me didn't
work I mean like the audience was
laughing but I don't know they didn't
make me laugh but a little weird scenes
like I love that there's one scene where
like the two mothers are fighting and
you know that the bad mother has the
good mother's head like down on the
table is gonna do you know something off
and the bad son goes that makes like
this creepy sound and the good mother
says that's yours
like that's hilarious cuz that's like
two mothers when they hear kid cry like
you know which ones they say oh that's
yours you know how they almost like
their friends but that and that's one of
those laughs that like it doesn't get a
laugh in the theatre but nevertheless
it's funny it's not something where you
like verbally necessarily laugh out loud
but you acknowledge now that that's
clever that that's pretty funny
um there's another great one I think
it's a very subtle joke we're in the
opening they have a Hall of Mirrors
which immediately a Jordan Peele movie
how can you not think to the halt of
mere sketch of what I saw that I'm just
like fighting my tongue like how I just
keep expecting to see them they're like
oh which one could I be but anyway but
the name of like the maze the hall of
mirror is something like how what is it
it's like some sort of like this kind of
racist Native American like it was a
shaman forest or something like that has
the big you know headdress and stuff
like that and then the person goes back
here is later and now it's Merlin's
forest and again you you just know what
happened because it took place in the
80s and then it's years later it's just
like oh that became on PC you know so
little touches like that I think you're
funny those are moments at the audience
didn't laugh at they laughed a little
bit more like just the traditional
one-liners that I didn't laugh at so
that already shows me there's kind of
enough variety here for the humor oh
where it's also kind of different from
get out it's strange cuz I'm saying to
myself I should I like this film more
than get out but I kind of rather watch
get out of a little more and I was
asking myself why and I think what it
came down to is that the acting in this
movie is very good all the actors are
great and you believe them when they're
alone when they have to interact as a
family I never bought them as a family
and I think the reason for that is that
all of their dialogue again is
it just jokes and they're not bad jokes
and their scenes where it's like okay I
can see a family saying that about don't
curse or like you know what what are
micromachines or sound like just making
kind of these little jokes but there's
never a scene where they like talk you
know what I mean it's always like oh
you're dead so dorky oh he got that
Boujis and stuff or one was trying to
act cool and failing like you know it's
it's a lot of that and I never felt like
they like connected or really talked
about anything that was real it was all
just kind of surface stuff
which again you could argue is kind of
the point and the more and more you find
out you could argue that's the idea but
because of that we'd get out there's a
little bit more of a humanity to it you
kind of felt like you knew these people
a little more so when there was a
surprise it was like whoa like holy
scene the surprise in the surprises and
this I mostly got but they're still good
and they're clever and they lead to kind
of a nice a nice commentary that I know
Reese I like this one a little bit more
and get out is we'd get out it's like
okay they're doing this one thing and
and it kind of surprises you where
they're going with and they're like oh
they're doing that instead of this I
sort of thought they're gonna go this
route okay but they still kind of go
with this one route where this one
it's just vague enough that it's like
okay you can read more into it you can
kind of look at this from different
angles you can look in terms of like
class you look in terms of races you can
look at terms of like just culture
Society light like all these different
angles but you can also look at just as
a horror film if that's why horror is so
great you can just look at as whatever
these are just crazy people going after
normal people or you can see it as like
this really really big satire this big
commentary and that it's so great that
way and Jordan Peele knows that and he
really has fun with it um so so you got
that going on but with that you you lose
a little bit of the
humanity which is not to say it's not
there at all but the latest movie works
the same way like the recent Halloween
that came out I guess not to reason but
the Halloween 2018 one came out a lot of
people liked it cuz they're like well
they're doing all the horror tropes that
we love all the Halloween tropes for me
that's boring the slasher tropes are
just kind of dull to me it's always one
guy going around killing you know and it
usually doesn't talk and but I get why
people like that they want to see the
formula and they want to see just the
slightest changes to it this one has a
little bit more of the tropes I think
are kind of fun when it comes to a
horror film where again a lot of the
comedy a lot of the scares a lot of the
create a lot of the enjoyment comes with
just how crazy the people are and the
killers are and their and against so
much of the comedy comes from that you
know these actors were like any day they
had to go as like themselves they're
like you know well okay I guess we'll
you know it will be the the frightened
family today but whenever they had to be
the crazy family like the insane one you
know they're like oh boy because they
just go so over-the-top so crazy the
best equivalent I can think of is that
it's like a Stephen King movie if it was
actually scary you know I've made fun
Stephen game before and stuff and the
movies and I do like a lot of them but
they're usually not scary
this is all the over-the-top tropes and
that may not roast but all the over top
stuff you would usually see in a Stephen
King story Plus kind of the scares you
know there's a good creep value to a lot
of it but you're you're also kind of
laughing with it too like the sounds the
other family makes you know a lot of
them don't talk you know they'll just
make these sounds and it's kind of it's
kind of funny whatever it happens and
the you know there's one where one of
the crazy family members is looking in
the mirror
like doing makeup and then taking now
you've been kind of getting your face
going you look out a window she'll start
crying and then start laughing and stuff
and that stuff is so crazy and really
creepy but really funny too cuz it's
just so over the top so that stuff I
really dig where it's hard for me to get
a little bit more into it again this is
why I think I technically like this film
more but I'd rather watch get out is
that get out kind of took place over a
long period of time and and like I said
the characters are very easy to relate
to
um you know you can laugh with them you
kind of feel like you're them where with
this one it's it's mostly over like 24
hours at the majority of the film and
again that kind of falls into like the
slasher category that I just I just
don't find as interesting it can be
really interesting you know just
following someone for one night but I
think it's I don't know I sometimes it
can be great sometimes it can just be
dull and I feel like this is such a
weird idea that you can kind of have fun
with and they do have fun with but
there's a lot of and get out where
there's like a lot of kind of talking
and you're seeing like the different
levels it can work on in a sense when
they're discussed when they're talking
this one there's a lot of sneaking
around there's a lot of looking around
the corner there's a lot of quiet
moments where people are just moving
very slowly and that's just dull to me I
know the idea is like it's supposed to
be building suspense but it's I don't
know it's like I respect that it goes
slow III go slower I respect that
actually tries to really not you know
hold your hand the whole time and do
jump scares all the time but it's also
just so slow and if you don't have quite
that connection to the people that at
least as a family unit that you should
that I think they're going for for the
most part
then I kind of feel like you're missing
something there when those slower
moments are happening but the actors are
good and every character is good I guess
I just never bought it
them actually as a family but again it's
by the time you get to the end you can
you know with what they're doing you
kind of say maybe that's the point
but it is a little it is a disconnect
throughout a good chunk of the film but
is still it's something where you're
watching it you're constantly going
what's going on why is this happening
how is it happening and I'll just say
right now the how is kind of on the same
levels Edward Scissorhands wear it
that's just not what it's about
you know with Everett Scissorhands it's
like oh there's just a mountain and this
inventor made a man and this man is
Scissorhands and he cuts ice well where
did the ice come from well I don't know
but that's what creates the snow every
year you know it's it's kind of like
that where you're not really supposed to
ask the tentacle so if you're real again
I feel like that's a little bit more
like the slasher film stuff where you
want like all the rules and stuff and
that's not how this works
this is not a movie that makes rules and
follows them and States very much no
we're gonna create an idea and we're
gonna play around with it a little bit
which again that does make it a little
tricky and scenes where they're just
sneaking around because then you're like
well how did these things work what does
kill them you know and it will just
falling down kill them or do you have to
hit them a million times to kill them
you know how do they communicate and
stuff like that you know so it's it's
one of those things where when you
really want to be afraid of these things
if that does kind of get in the way too
so so that is that is a problem but it's
not a major problem in my opinion I I
was happy when I got to the end because
I was really afraid that this was just
gonna be a sneaking around movie and
just get away from the killer movie like
when they introduced the family the
other family and they meet up and one of
them starts talking I was like okay they
they got something going here you could
actually stop right here and you could
read stuff into this so I was happy with
that but then it mostly just goes into
the chase it's mainly
chase movie you know horror still you
know in comedy but but mainly a chase
movie and I was really afraid kind of
the ideas disappeared
and I'll say myself that doesn't sound
right he's got to bring him back and at
the end he does um
maybe even to a confusing extent the guy
won't give it away but the final shot in
this movie when you kind of see what's
going on and what a lot of it I should
say not all of it but a lot of its
building up to I didn't quite get it
which isn't bad I mean it's not
something I watch I'm just like I don't
fit into Britney or whatever but I was
kind of like no because everything else
in this is let vague enough I feel like
I kind of want to create ideas of what
that could mean or what that's about
but yeah it's one of the few times where
I left now it's just like yeah
everything else I kind of got or I could
read something in and that one I'm not
getting uh it's like the balls being
thrown at me I can see but I'm just not
able to catch it so I'm curious if other
people you know other people have seen
it uh you know obviously if you can't go
in the comments you know there's gonna
be spoilers there and stuff but you know
like what your take on that was because
I wasn't sure
it just seemed odd it seemed very odd
and I know it's even kind of being set
up earlier it just seemed weird I really
didn't fully get it me just to show how
large it was I don't know but still this
is it's a chase movie that's mainly a
horror film has a lot of elements of
comedy the comedy works best when it
comes from the situation out as much
kind of the zingers of a lot of zingers
actually and I love a big you know big
laughs but it but that item I have to
hard at them but that's me being snobby
so yeah I do recommend this film I there
are elements of get out but it's it's
not quite get out it really is something
a little different we're in the first
one that's you know kind of a horror
film where somebody's
in a place and you're trying to figure
out what's going on this one's very much
it's over the course of about 24 hours
and it's a chase and it's a lot of
sneaking around and stuff like that you
know that's kind of the main idea behind
this one and both of them not
surprisingly have like a lot of
commentary a lot of subtext to it and I
like the subtext of this one a lot more
I like the ideas of this one a lot more
if you told me the story of both of them
I'd just be like man that that us I like
that one but there is a hint more of a
disconnect then there wasn't get out I
could definitely relate to the people
and get out a lot more but again that
that's kind of the tricky part of this
movie is that we get to the end it's
like okay then maybe that was
intentional but but but while you're
watching it it does create a disconnect
that makes it a little trickier so yeah
I definitely say check it out I'm
curious since this has yeah you know it
probably does every watch ability to it
I don't know how many people are going
to catch on to what's going I caught on
to one major element that was going on
pretty early on but everything else in
terms of what was the big scheme what
was like I didn't know is so I think I
think for the most part this is gonna
have people coming back to want to watch
it again I don't know if it's gonna be
as much as get out cuz get out was legit
like kind of fun you were being scared
and laughing at the same time where this
one's oh it's loud but there's a you
have to wade through a lot of quiet
parts of sneaking and should all that
stuff to get to the loud parts but
people like that too they liked a quiet
place they liked a lot of these you know
slasher films and thrillers so so I
think it'll do okay I think people are
mostly gonna like this film that the
last shot might throw them off of it
okay like this when it was done people
are having fun throughout most of the
film but it wasn't like an applause
moment at the Abbey we're just kind of
like you know which is OK
you know get out was the big whoa you
know that's that's the the movie you
wanna plug at the end and this one
I think just want people walking away
kind of thinking like huh okay so when
that happened could that be this or
maybe that's kind of tying in to what
this was I like it's it's one of those
movies and I think that's all right cuz
I don't want just the exact same thing
after get out I don't really know if
anyone does you know if they did they
just make it out to and even then we
wouldn't really want get out too we will
want something different so uh so I dug
it I really thought it was a pretty cool
movie and yeah I I think I think there's
a lot there there's a lot to kind of
open up and analyze but you can also
just see it as straightforward horror
film to you can definitely go in just
bring a date why to go ah you know that
kind of stuff so I definitely say check
it out I think was really cool and I
would you see it the next review take
care
you